je sais je sais jusqu'au bout de
soi-même
la séance en elle-même là est
dure ah elle toute seule elle se suffit
Alice vient d'enchaîner deux fois 250 m
avec Jérémy son partenaire
d'entraînement du
jour vite ça je peux le
dire 6e au dernier champion du monde de
Paris l'été dernier Alice vise la
sélection sur 400 m au prochain
paralympique récupère
récupère par sa détermination déjà donc
c'est une fille qui qui qui bosse
sérieusement et elle sait pourquoi elle
est là sur la piste il y a beaucoup
d'athlètes des fois ils savent pas trop
pourquoi on va à l'entraînement mais
elle a aussi son objectif surtout pour
pour les Jeux Olympiques reste bien sur
la
pointe solide au sol solide PAP appuie
fort son handicap il n'est pas visible
et justement il concerne sa vue alice
est atteinte d'une maladie que rare de
naissance elle n'a qu'un diè à chacœil
un champ visuel réduit et une forte
sensibilité à la
lumière autre lieu autre souffrance
outre les séances de muscu Alice vient
chaque semaine se faire soigner chez
Émilie depuis leur rencontre les deux
femmes ont noué un lien évident ça
venait
allier trois choses qui me plaisent mon
métier de kiné la notion de handicap que
j'éis avec lesquel j'ai j'ai pendant un
certain nombre d'années et le sport de
haut niveau que j'ai pratiqué mais il y
a très longtemps donc c'était un peu le
cadeau c'est la la seule de mes
patientes à qui je réponds le
weekend une complicité indispensable à
Alice c'est pas que des soins physiques
parce qu'on discute elle me elle me
conseille des fois elle me rassure aussi
et puis on il y a une équipe et et elle
peut des fois quand je vais pas bien
parler au aux entraîneurs pour alerter
pour faire attention enfin donc c'est
pas que du soin physique non
heureusement la jeune femme originaire
du blanc est licenciée à la berichonne
de châurou mais elle vit et s'entraîne à
tour depuis 3 ans le sport a pris une
dimension déterminante dans son
quotidien j'acceptais pas du tout mon
handicap quand j'ai commencé le sport et
c'est mes parents qui m'ont poussé à à
pratiquer une activité physique pour me
faire du bien mentalement pour me faire
rencontrer des gens aussi et pour me
prouver à moi-même que j'étais capable
de faire certaines choses malgré le
handicap et le sport m'a vraiment aidé à
à comprendre et à accepter tout
ça retour à l'entraînement une journée
riche caralis travaille également à
mi-temps c'est une décision de ma part
de continuer de travailler parce que je
voulais pas faire que du sport donc je
suis chargée de communication et de
marketing dans une belle entreprise où
je m'épanouis vraiment et ça me permet
aussi d'avoir un équilibre et de pouvoir
m'épanouir dans autre chose que le sport
pour se qualifier Alice devra sans doute
réaliser des minimas autour des 58
secondes d'ici juillet et être
sélectionné parmi les trois athlètes
françaises retenu ces atouts ell possède
le 6e temps mondial et une détermination
hors norme tous ces efforts c'est pour
l'objectif final c'est pour essayer de
me qualifier au jeu donc j'y passe du
temps j'y vais sous la pluie mais c'est
pour un bel objectif que j'espère
atteindre donc c'est pour ça que je
continue d' aller avec le sourire malgré
toutzvous cet été à
Paris